meta is facing the largest data
protection fine ever issued under EU law
gdpr is five years old this week and
this will give privacy campaigners
something to celebrate though Brussels
knows meta will appeal do you want to
bring back legal certainty Clarity with
this decision it's clear I think all the
commissioner said this before that we
expect it would also be challenged at
some point but the bottom line is we are
working on the basis of the safe quest
that the courts demanded an appeal
should by matter time to come up with a
solution something to persuade the EU
its citizens data is protected from
snooping by the U.S security agencies
for example
a new data sharing agreement expected
this summer should help but that isn't
expected to solve a very thorny issue
for Facebook which is what to do with
about a decades worth of EU users data
stored on servers in the US
does it delete the lot can it even do
that
it's a logistical challenge that could
take years I'm not sure of the degree to
which metal would know that that bucket
of data is purely the data of EU users
and that bucket of data is purely the
data of Australian users or us users I'm
I think it's a very very big task for
them to try and Carry Out
meta says the decision sets a dangerous
precedent for other companies what's
likely is they're ensuing legal Wrangler
over data will make an already
complicated situation more so take
companies operating in the UK not
affected by this EU decision but using
very similar gdpr laws smaller firms
risk falling foul of the rules while big
companies like meta can afford the
lawyers to stay ahead of The Regulators
Tom Clark Sky News